meet professor Jim and tattoo he claims
to have uploaded a special video of
himself playing a harmonica but is it
real we've all seen x-rays but how about
a moving x-ray of a person playing the
harmonica I've taken x-rays in my life
but I've never seen an x-ray video it
was an extraordinary sight to see the
movement of the bones as well as
obviously the harmonica
well this amazing footage is real so how
is it done
x-rays are radiation just like normal
light except they're working at a
different frequency and as a result they
have a higher energy and they go through
flesh and are only blocked by bones but
how do you film an x-ray is there some
special x-ray camera normal x-ray
machine will will transmit the x-rays on
to the subject and then the x-ray
sensitive paper will react accordingly
and give us a sort of still image of the
broken bone or ever what he's done here
is instead of it hitting x-ray material
it hits a fluoroscope and that is a very
clever device that turns the x-rays into
fluorescent light and then from the back
he's able to video that with an old
video camera Jim submitted himself to
the equivalent of about three months
worth of radiation to make this clip but
don't try this at home high doses of
x-rays definitely aren't good for you
high doses of x-ray radiation can cause
mutation and cancer so fluoroscope are
to be avoided unless absolutely
necessary